Hey, Vsauce.
Michael here.
And we now have 200 videos.
So, to celebrate, I'm going to recommend some
videos.
200 of them, inside playlists, especially
ones that you guys have been submitting to
me.
But to begin, let's go all the way back to
the start.
Or, more correctly, the RestartPage.com.
I found this on Boing Boing.
The page contains dialog boxes from operating
systems through history.
Click one and your entire browser recreates
the actual restart.
But if you want to be more involved, be like
Suckmynose000, who recommended this visualization
of "Lights," where you can fly around in electrically
synchronised world of lights.
2MoronsAndAnIdiot sent me "Perfect Eyesight."
How accurately can you click in the exact
right spot?
For instance, the exact mathematical middle
of this star.
Nice.
Now, I've covered so many playlists before.
For instance this one, containing the very
first hour of MTV ever.
Well, a couple of days ago, CGPGrey released
this winning playlist of his 30 favorite videos,
ranging from comedy to art to music to science
to horror.
It's an amazing collection of cool stuff that
also let's you get closer to Grey.
RealNintendo put together this playlist of
7 epic game show fails.
He says they get crazier as it goes, so keep
watching.
Hunter F. Davies made 4 playlists: Funny 911
Calls, Great Explosions, 7 incredible historical
Apple ads and 3 videos about why the world
won't end in 2012.
Now, here's a great one.
28 commercials for video game systems in order
from 1973 to 2011.
Maddog53 collected his 15 favorite YouTube
videos of 2011, many of which were new to
me and are quite beautiful.
MrBeanmachine17 assembled 7 incredible nuclear
bomb detonation videos in order of increasing
explosive yield.
But if you'd rather relax, check out this
community - driving videos.
Sped up footage of people driving their cars
through freeway systems in lots of different
states.
It's actually pretty cool to have on full
screen in the background like moving artwork.
I received this playlist of cool music and
was reminded of Hadouken's "People Are Awesome."
So I made this playlist containing 5 of the
best made People Are Awesome clips ever.
We may not have claws or beaks or tails, but
at least we can do this.
Want more inspiration?
Grevejp44 sent me this playlist of epic orchestral
arrangements - be sure to play it when preparing
for battle.
Oh and here's a thing.
You know when you see "As Seen On" on YouTube?
Well, you can click it and arrive on a page
showing every YouTube video that site has
featured and you can even subscribe to their feed.
So rather than figure out all the channels
worth following yourself, heck, let Reddit
do the work for you.
Or, Cute Overload.
Or a sub-reddit that will deliver video meant
to non-plus your mind.
The new YouTube channel layout makes people's
feeds fantastic automatic playlists.
See, rather than having to find other videos
related by keywords, I can find things related
because the same human liked them.
For instance, I love sword dancing, but related
videos only give me more swords and a girl
in a tanktop.
But by opening the video from 'temperature3's'
feed, I get this module, which introduces me
to other things that he liked or favorited.
Now, the same goes for my friend Jake's personal
channel.
His list of favorites and likes is like going
to cool things wing of the Jake Museum and
Jake is the museum's curator.
If you've made a playlist of types of videos
you think we should all know about, keep them
coming my way - michael@vsauce.com.
And as always,
thanks for watching.